next another look at what House members
are allowed to say on the House floor
last week a Democratic member had her
remark stricken from the record for what
she said about the house speaker today
questions are raised about some remarks
by Republican congressman Robert Dornan
of California on President Clinton this
portion runs about ten minutes for what
purpose does the gentleman from
California rise for the first time this
year Mr Speaker I ask unanimous consent
to address the house for one minute
revise maybe extend my remarks and ask
for a soft gavel the gentleman is
recognized for one minute mr. speaker my
good friend John Lewis the only - an
either chamber that were there the day
Martin Luther King gave his stirring
speech I hate to disagree with him on
anything but I was offended by Clinton's
speech last night on 15 points and I'll
do a five minute special order tonight
that I've just signed up for
I can only mention four the first one is
new covenant the Ark of the Covenant was
the old covenant the new covenant was
the son of God Jesus Christ and I was
offended when he used that term in New
York at the Democratic convention and he
repeated it over and over and over again
last night
number two to put a Medal of Honor
winner in the gallery that joined the
Marine Corps at 16 fudging his birth
certificate they pulled that second
grenade under his stomach miraculously
surviving and saving his four friends he
did that six days past his 17th birthday
does Clinton think putting a Medal of
Honor winner up there isn't going to
recall for most of us that he avoided
the draft three times and put teenagers
in his place possibly to go to Vietnam
number three the line on the Cold War
even Andrea Mitchell of NBC took note
that that's Ronald Reagan's prerogative
George Bush's and all of us who wore the
uniform or served in civilian capacities
to crush the evil empire Clinton gave
aid and comfort to the enemy and by the
way mr. speaker the Second Amendment is
not for killing little ducks and leaving
Huey and doing Louis without an aunt and
uncle
it's for hunting politicians like Grozny
1776 when they take your independence
away
thank you speak are you back the bill is
now expired
all right
do I need to say that
all right for what purpose does
gentleman you can't just do all members
will suspend the clerk will report the
words spoken by the gentleman members
were not on the floor including myself
when the gentleman's uh turd his words
is it possible to have those words read
back so that we can all hear it the
gentleman is correct clerk will report
the words I want the speaker to say that
I didn't hear the speaker the clerk will
report the word even Andrea Mitchell of
NBC took note that is Ronald Reagan's
prerogative George Bush's and all of us
who wore the uniform or served in a
civilian capacity to crush the evil
empire Clinton gave aid and comfort to
the enemy
in the opinion of the chair that is not
a proper reference to the president
mister without objection the words are
stricken from the record reserving the
right to object without objection the
deserving the right to object I think
the gentleman from California owes the
entire institution the Congress and the
president an apology hell no we have a
calendar in chief we have to have a
certain decorum here and a respect for
the body if not for the individual we
have to have a respect for the person
who is our commander-in-chief I would
like to know that the gentleman from
California not only understands that but
will apologize to his colleagues and to
the president for his behavior mr.
speaker or Natomas consent to uh speak
for 15 seconds reserving the right to
object the gentleman from California mr.
feyo has the floor at this moment I'd
like it here I'd be happy to yield to my
colleague from California since I have
the time to hear his response but Jim
O'Neill I'd be happy to yield the
gentleman from California to my
distinguished friend and colleague Major
Earl Coble Lieutenant Commander JJ
Connell were beaten to death in Hanoi I
have had friends beaten to death and
handle a torture to beat you have not
with all due respect I've asked the
gentleman éclairs not only not apologize
I believe the President did give aid and
comfort in London to the enemy in Hanoi
I'll accept the discipline of the
highest at the California we take it
down good I will leave the floor no
apology cannot speak the rest require
the truth is the truth mr. speaker the
gym the house will be in order the
gentleman's words have already been
taken down those words the tools were
man is challenging the world's your
hunter in response to my question those
words were also out of order the chair
has ruled that based on the precedence
of the house the words of the speaker
we're out of order and without objection
the work that works will be stricken
from the record from this
not effect unless sight I don't get a
satisfactory answer to my concerns my
concerns were with frankly more than
just the words that were read I was
particularly concerned with the the last
sentence or two of the gentleman from
California's statement and I would like
those words as well to be read to the
house has just ruled that those words
were the same words essentially as those
earlier taken down and previously ruled
out ordered has ruled that deserving the
right of Jack I think the gentleman of
the chair misinterprets my comments and
perhaps I wasn't clear the words that I
am referring to were the original
1-minute statement by the gentleman from
California mr. Dornan and I'm
particularly concerned with the last two
lines of it and I would like them right
back to the house gentleman will state
his inquiry the general the speaker in
previous days of it has asked that the
gentleman in question on words being
taken down be seated would that not be a
proper request to be made at this point
that is correct the gentleman from
California should be sated at this point
with gentleman yield
with gentleman yield from Michigan sure
the gentleman from California did say
that he understood the rules of the
house that he'd been censured under
rules house for what he said and he
would not speak for the next 24 hours on
the floor of the house and it strikes me
that we're operating under the rules and
we had to move on with it I I think the
request made by the gentleman from
California mr. Fazzio is still a valid
and much-needed request and in addition
to that I would certainly like to hear
the last two lines of the gentleman's
original gentleman yield I would yield
to my friend I would like to ask a
parliament query of the speaker at this
point little studies inquire when the
speaker rules that the gentleman should
not be allowed to speak for 24 hours
does that encompass remarks that might
be placed in the record participation in
special orders and other activities that
might not involve the gentleman speaking
on the floor
it is the houses determination as to
whether or not the members should be
allowed to proceed in order termination
shall not be made by the parliamentarian
in other words is the house required to
vote on whether or not remarks are
alleged in the record on parliamentary
remarks cannot be inserted in the record
but remarks that are not ruled
unparliamentary may be placed in the
record if they're not uttered on the
floor is that the ruling of the speaker
on parliamentary remarks should not be
inserted in the record in any manner or
form they should not be inserted at any
time but there is a particular provision
that we're dealing with here which
removes the member from the ability to
communicate with his colleagues here is
that communication written as well as
oral the the gentleman is correct that's
that so in other words just to confirm
the speaker's ruling we won't read or
hear from mr. Dornan for the next 24
hours is that correct
unless the house permits him to proceed
in order the gentleman is correct and
for the house to permit that would
require a majority vote it would require
either unanimous consent or a majority
vote of the house appreciate the speaker
for clarifying the situation thank you
gentleman is on his feet is is he not
supposed to remain seated until the
determination is that gentleman can
either leave the chamber are be seated
and they chose to leave the chamber okay
want to hear these words is it the
chairs understanding that original words
in the original one-minute are